I think the first thing to say is of
course that um Mr Hunt was presenting
with a slightly better fiscal Outlook
than he faced in November but don't
forget it's still much worse than we
expected a year ago it's very much too
easy to compare these numbers with the
most recent ones actually looking back
even a little way in history is quite
important Mr Hunt decided to spend the
larger part of the windfall that he's
got since November but note the
difference with what happened in
November then the forecast got much
worse he just lived with the extra
borrowing
so if they get better and you borrow
when you use the extra borrowing they
get worse and you keep the extra
borrowing that's how borrowing ratchet
is ratchet up year on year
the two big ticket items were a child
care offer for the under threes and a
temporary full expensive for expensing
for investments in corporation tax there
was more money for defense than the
traditional and this time particularly
expensive cut in the real terms level of
fuel Duty
as far as economic forecasts are
concerned the obr are much more positive
than the bank of England and the many
other forecasters about medium-term
growth the chance they should be
grateful at least for that small Mercy
but to repeat what I said back in
November is slightly odd I don't know if
it's damaging but it's certainly
slightly odd that we have our monetary
policy and our fiscal policy made on the
basis of two extremely different
economic forecasts
despite uh those uh relatively somewhat
uh better
um economic forecasts uh over at least
the short run the outlook for the public
finances does still look difficult
tax continues to rise to its highest
ever level and to much higher levels
than in recent decades yet even with
very tight spending penciled in from
2024 debt is barely falling and that's
because a high debt level high debt
interest payments additions to debt not
included in borrowing and sluggish
nominal growth make it hard to get debt
on a decisively downward path this
really matters to quote the obr it is
now harder for this Chancellor to
deliver a falling path for the debt to
GDP ratio in the medium term than it has
been for any of his predecessors since
the obr was established in 2010 that's
quite a statement not least remembering
where we were back in 2010
as a result Mr Hunt was hemmed in by his
own fiscal Target to get debt falling in
the last year of the forecast period
while it's level the level of debt that
is is expected to be lower than November
the trajectory remains stubbornly flat
and that has led him to rely on a
combination of tight spending plans
imaginary future increases in fuel
duties and a fiscal gain from
unwillingly undoing its corporation tax
change at the end of the period in order
to appear to meet this rule this is not
a terribly sensible way of being Guided
by such rules
that said this budget did lay out some
elements of a sensible strategy to
support growth there's plenty to quibble
with and I will quibble but if you want
to focus on growth there's at least some
of what you might want here attempting
to deal with incentives to work and to
invest now much of the focus was on
getting more people back to work the OVR
rewarded the chancellor by suggesting he
might have some success in this but the
numbers are modest
if the total effect of the measures is
indeed to get just over a hundred
thousand more people into work as the
obr suggests and let's be clear that is
a very uncertain forecast that would be
just a fraction of the number lost from
the workforce in the last couple of
years alone it's dwarf by annual net
immigration numbers assumed that 245 000
even the change in assumptions about
migration increases the numbers in work
by 160 000 over the period the obr
reckon the overall labor Supply package
will cost about 7 billion a year and
increase employment by around a hundred
and ten thousand that's a cost of nearly
70 000 per job obviously the money will
do other things like provide child care
but it given the Chancellor's focus on
increasing the numbers of jobs I think
that's an interesting calculation to
make